[Music]
everybody going
in wake up early in the morning press
play and let's get it in cause we
rocking with the fighter and he
[Music]
look into it look into it because we got
misha tate on the show welcome
welcome thank you you came in from where
vegas so vegas is home now because
uh you lived in singapore for a while
correct
like about a year and a half and it was
supposed to be two years but the
pandemic kind of put a
kibosh on that you know did they did
they really locked down during the month
oh yeah
so super super strict and i was like i
was super super pregnant
so you think about that is like my mom
couldn't come over for the birth all
those things just happened the borders
locked down and then you couldn't leave
your house without a mask it's not like
here you know where you can kind of
break the rules and like there's not
enough there's too many people to
enforce it not there
not there they have like ambassadors
walking around wearing ambassador shirts
and they'll straight up tickets you
and that must have been so scary like
they came people and [ __ ] not that i
think they'd came you for not wearing a
mask
you know what i'm saying right it's just
like you don't get away with the portion
yeah because it's clean too right
very clean like you're not allowed to
spit on the ground they don't sell
chewing gum
it's technically not allowed there but
it's kind of like if you bring it down
on your own and you just don't say
anything like nobody says anything but
if you're getting a lot you get yeah for
sure whenever i came in because they're
coming from america
taking trips back i felt like i was like
a drug dealer because
you want something like everyone would
be so excited oh my gosh you got that
wristlet
i know you got it
24 packs of gum you know and it's like
but
singapore was a good experience it was a
good experience
it was an experience it was definitely
something i'm glad that i did but i will
never do it again
why i just uh you know culturally it was
a
it was a bit of a culture shock um like
the people over there they
they are not i don't know like i kind of
want to say they're just they're they're
not very culturally
accepting of like differences you know
what i mean like here in like america i
feel like we're a melting pot we kind of
just accept everybody or like that's the
way i feel anyways and like most people
i associate with her that way
but it's like some old like chinese man
will be like not give you the time of
day
like everyone was like yelling at me for
feeding my kid on the way to the airport
in the taxi
he was got so mad he's like why are you
feeding your kid right now we're not
supposed to feed it feed them in the car
i'm like
they're like little like those little
finger things that like babies can eat
i'm like
i'm feeding them because i'm a mom and i
know how hard it's going to be to feed
them once i get to the airport trying to
get through security on the plane all
that stuff
i want to make sure like sorry like i'll
make sure your car is cleaned up but he
was
not having it like that kind of stuff
you know what i mean like people are not
very empathetic interesting there i
would say overall like not very
empathetic
kind of stressful yeah a little bit
stressful good experience though
oh yeah i mean it's you know it's not
every day you get to pick up and move
across the world and live in another
country and experience
asia and i think the best part about
living in singapore is like it's very
safe
and really the best thing about living
there is to get out of singapore
yeah it's so small i mean you really can
see the whole thing in two weeks
it's tiny really very small it's like 40
minutes
from like one side to 45 minutes maybe
when you had off time would you travel
around asia oh yeah like
i said yes or no well i mean i suppose
if you go to the wrong places yeah but
you know where to go
um i mean usually i was traveling with
one championship so it was like
you know what i mean they don't they're
not picking areas that are
so you know but uh there it is
it's so weird i looked it on the map the
other day and i was like i can't believe
i lived there
that's nuts yeah like i lived at the
marina bay residence down in that like
almost where that makes that v
right there um okay yeah so you see
sands basically right there
yeah like i basically lived right yeah
have you guys seen this
good setup good touch on that again
right there because you'll see what the
marina bay
so that's that's like the iconic piece
of singer i didn't live in that but i
had a view of that
oh like right across the lake there's a
you live
i know right no that's a casino um and
then with one championship they
set you up with housing and everything
or did you have to figure no i had to i
mean they helped me find the housing but
that was like on my own to
pay for that i think so but they paid me
well so and for the
for the listeners and viewers the reason
you're in singapore is because you are
working with one championship
yeah it was basically based out of
singapore i don't know that was based
out of singapore
yeah and your your experience with uh
one championship
i thought it was great that they brought
you on board especially with your
knowledge and your
your fight game your the history of all
that stuff so smart they brought you on
board
and then i was surprised because you're
coming back to the ufc now
so i guess
when you decide to come out of
retirement obviously the ufc owns your
rights i don't know if people realize
that
yeah no i people don't seem to realize
that so so so so i'm retired right yeah
so if i decide to come back and let's
add six fights or four fights left on my
contract okay it's not because i retire
they're like okay go have fun you can do
whatever you want no no
they just freeze your contract yep so
when she retired it's not like like all
right misha
have a nice life unless you finish your
contract because you finish your
contract but if you decide to retire
midway through it freezes yeah
so when you come back you have to fight
for how long are these they own your
rights how long are these contracts
well it's not years it's fights it's
fights well how many fights do you have
six or eight
just a bit but especially these days
they do six they do long
long contracts so you can't just bounce
which would be with equivalent of about
two years typically like if you fought
usually three fights a year is what most
fighters or at least what the
ufc guarantees you is three fights a
year if you get injured obviously
they extend your contract in time you
know so if you're not able to fight
or whatever but um they'll guarantee you
those three fights it's about a two-year
contract two years
so when when you decide to come out of
retirement did you
have to let one championship know so are
you still my question is so are you
still working for one championship than
fighting for the ufc
so i in a perfect world that'd be what
i'd want to do because i'd be making
bank that way on both sides but you
should be able to
i mean yes and no i mean they're they're
competing companies at the end of the
day
you know what i mean it's there they're
doing the same thing but in a different
way
but competing for you know for
viewership so i guess
i don't know i mean it's good for you
it's good for one championship you know
yeah i agree oh no one championship's
down they would definitely have you know
right that makes sense yep they don't
play well with others
no they don't they don't play well
the freezing like you have to finish
those fights you have to before you
can't go anywhere
before you can go anywhere else you have
so if you have two fights i don't know
how many fights you have left in your
contract
six oh you've did it for a while girl
wow i think it was the eighth fight that
i signed at the
championship and then i had that fight
and then i had one more and then so i
have six more
so she has six with ufc so she can't go
anywhere until you fight six times
unless they cut her yeah unless they
listen or release me
she's too big of a name yeah okay so
that she's a huge name but then i went
to work for one championship as the vice
president so maybe that's where it gets
a little like if you didn't understand
that i wasn't complaining
i wasn't fighting oh yeah
president one championship who's a
different organization but they're all
doing this
big and asian same sport yeah they're
huge in asia
but out here yeah they got uh elaine the
dude from africa
big buff guy yeah you know talking about
yeah
yeah yeah yeah
over there but that was what won that
championship
championship oh the one that just bought
uh yeah this last wednesday on this one
he got
starched wait wait he's which i think is
good for one championship you talk about
dj
obviously yeah yeah i want to clarify
because you said eddie too like i just
won't let people know like the eddie
alvarez situation that was weird that
was right
there you got legal shots that's weird i
don't but but i i think for
mighty mouse it was it's good for one
championship
bad for mighty mouse obviously but you
know with the other thing
inside baseball here they have different
rules so if i'm fight if misha let's say
shows her next fight's in the ufc
so if she's fighting ufc she can't knee
a down opponent
yes one championship you can knee a down
opponent
so and demetrius johnson is a huge
advocate for that which i am also i
think
i think if you should be able to kneel
in the head okay let me just
let me back this up real quick let me
just break this down why i think that
this should be allowed
it's my name um so
if you're allowed to kick someone in the
head standing and they can fall
and you're allowed to knee them standing
you know and all these things so you
could flying knee them which
is a lot of momentum going i think
grapplers get enough [ __ ] for not being
able to like make fights exciting right
we always get that
yeah i get those finishes you know i was
like oh it's laying prey well then give
us all the
tools that we get on the feet let us
need people on the head i'm gonna
take that away from us on the ground
yeah i'm gonna piggyback on that because
i do a show called what's up with
brendan shop
and fans call in with questions or
debates and this guy made a great point
he goes you know russians and
dagestanians are taking over the ufc and
mixed martial arts
and they're so grappling heavy he goes i
think what would help
these other fighters so to make it less
boring
is if they could knee on the ground so
they have some sort of tool to finish
them
i'm with you so why don't they let them
know that's a fatality
yeah uh because some commissioner
somewhere decided it didn't look safe
like a 12 to 6 elbow which is the
dumbest so they did the rules a long
time ago and they thought because of
those kung fu movies were
or you see those weird taekwondo
combinations yeah where they're breaking
boards like this or like that could kill
somebody
so they said that i'm serious
that's always been the rule for ufc yeah
you can't do the need
and to get rules change is a night it
takes forever
there's different commissions it's just
so what you got to go and nobody wants
to admit that they
thought it was a dumb idea to begin with
i feel like some people are stuck on
that too like oh we just don't want to
you know we don't want to admit that
it's kind of like code that wasn't like
code like newsome's gone so far this way
where he's like even though he knows
he's wrong he
his ego he's like none of that will not
let him he double down even though cdc's
i guess six foot doesn't make any sense
now
it can be three and you guys are fine
he's like nope still six foot because he
doubled down on that he double down on
it so that's kind of like fighting
they're like no
we doubled down on it yeah oh man but to
to uh explain to one championship that's
a different rule set so you are allowed
to knee
out to a grounded appointment and one
championship and dj like myself
also an advocate for it ends up getting
finished with the knee to the head on
the ground
did i get down the finish i didn't see
it oh it's so bad
but it's a bummer because the other
bummer is you can't really train
that so i think dj obviously he's been
fighting ufc
forever was pounded around goats of all
time
and when you're not used to that and
then when it goes live heat of the
moment i think he forgot
me too because you're not trained yeah
well he looks so surprised when that
happened
he just you know show that like and it's
weird for me to like even i was like oh
my god oh it's real ugly well cause i'm
uh yeah yeah yeah i [ __ ] with you that's
my [ __ ] yeah i'm alumni so when i
watch it and i see the knees my initial
thoughts like oh my god what's he doing
it's like oh yeah they can do that they
can do that
yeah it's so it's so violent but also
it's not to your point it's not more
violent you can kick to the face with a
shin
i thought you know when i saw that what
do you mean and then and then he fell on
his face after he got knocked
out too it's like here it is so
he gets clipped before right there he
goes to get up and he's like i'll just
get back to my feet
[Applause]
boom
but i think they have a star in the
making there though with adriana because
now he's going to get that demetrius
johnson rubble
a little bit you know it becomes i mean
demetra is a goat yeah
and michael and eddie were on food truck
before
and i was saying him like you know he's
tough but you beat tougher guys and he
was like huh
i don't like that man he's like because
it puts pressure i mean these guys are
really good
but they're not big in the american
market he's like this guy's a monster
man yeah he is a black belt
and did you notice that they look like
they're in two different weight classes
like demetrius is just small he was like
a foot shorter look at that boy
that's basically just goes to show you
that you can be the greatest fighter of
all time
but you fight somebody you know
potentially 10 pounds bigger than you
mind you they did weigh in the same but
i guarantee you dj probably had a five
course breakfast that morning it was
drinking water and like he just can't
gain weight i know that
and so in comparison to that the flying
knee that mosfet all did in comparison
to that
the flying knee was way more powerful
than
that yeah that was a hard ball
what made ben so bad is he's he his
momentum is coming forward oh yes
he's running he's running they're both
running it yeah and mazavital sprinted
into that i mean he was
running his whole body forward i mean
that was a powerful knee right there on
the ground but
you know it was the knee generated as
opposed to the whole body momentum
behind that
and then the face plant of ben askren i
mean i just make the argument that i
don't think it's any more i don't think
it's
worse it's not any worse it's tough to
prove that it's worse than anything else
that made my heart
i don't know how that's exactly right
that made my heart sink you know
i you know i'm balls to even find that
yeah i was like oh my god
it's like how was dj okay i shot my text
like you all right man
that's tough you're just not used to it
yeah yeah of course i mean
let's take a little break from our chat
with the great misha tate cause listen
did you know more than 50 million men in
the us suffer from male pattern baldness
that's right 50 million dudes are losing
their hair
but guess what you need to check out
keeps keeps offers a simple stress free
way
to keep what you have keep your hair man
it's a convenient virtual doctor
you check out with them all right and
then you get medication
sent to your door every three months you
never have to leave your house
it's low-cost treatments start at just
ten dollars per month and keeps offers
generic versions all right
comes a discreet little package nobody
has to know that you're doing this with
your hair to show up with some locks son
all right prevention is the key
treatment can take four to six months to
see results so act fast
because you're already missing summer so
hopefully the fall your hair is popping
man get on it if you're ready to take
action
prevent hair loss go to keeps.com
fighter
that's k-e-e-p-s dot com slash fighter
all right receive your first month free
of treatment that's keeps.com
fighter get your first month free
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash fighter
hey you little thickies maybe you maybe
you enjoy yourself a nice cold one be
like too many carbs i don't get that
thick
i got you covered man you need to start
living a healthy lifestyle and it's
tough
and i get it so guess what you need to
check out coors pure
because it's organic and has zero sugar
you can enjoy it without feeling guilty
you don't want that heavy feeling of the
normal bear anymore you don't want to do
that man
all right so you got to check them out
because again it's organic beer that is
about celebrating the winds of life
every day it's organic but they're chill
about it all right
coors pure organic but not chill about
it new course beer is refreshing simple
beer with organic barley organic hops
and water
has only 92 calories zero sugar which is
the big one because of sugar and a lot
of beers guys
it's the perfect bear to celebrate the
winds of life every day get
on it man coors pure is the perfect bear
to celebrate the winds of everyday life
i keep telling you guys that
so thick is cool but don't be too thick
and have a bear gut so this is going to
help you out man so we want to enjoy
bear
without the guilt reach for coarse pure
it's organic but they're chill about it
all right
go to coorspure.com to see where you can
find coors pure
again go to coorspeer.com to see where
you can find coors pure
celebrate responsibly coors brewing
company
albany georgia it's tough
you're just not used to it yeah yeah of
course i mean and then and then at one
championship you guys have different
weigh-in yeah they do the hydration
testing which
break that down for these guys so they i
forget the name of the little device but
essentially they take urine and they put
it in this device that measures the
how hydrated you are essentially by how
much waste is in your urine so when you
get really dehydrated you know that your
urine turns all dark and stuff there's
not enough water so it's very
concentrated the more hydrated you are
the more clear it is
so it measures that basically through
like a gravity process
if i'm saying that right you guys hope
that makes sense right yeah there's more
particles water versus particles of
waste and
that's essentially what it is they just
measure how hydrated you are through
your urine
so then if you're in an outside so if
you fight out because so
how does the weight division work so
let's say you fight at 135
then you could weigh in at 145. you ten
so like one weight class up
interesting yeah so ten pounds i don't
know if i'm
yeah i don't know if i'm on board with
that so you look at mighty mouse there
that was tough man
yeah he just doesn't get you know he'd
have to cut
a little bit to make 125 before he said
that but i was always part of the
process and then he was
on par with everybody else where now i
just feel like these guys
you know and there's a little flux to
cut a little bit of weight with that you
know you can cut a couple pounds and
still be within hydration you just can't
cut
massively to where it's you know yeah
damaging like you see a lot of people do
that and they're just like they're out
of it
you know what i mean like they're they
cut so much weight 20 pounds
how much did you did you used to cut i
never cut the only time i kept was for a
jiu jitsu match i got down to 222. yeah
and i found out the other guy didn't
have to cut but they didn't tell me that
but heavy weight
know it's 206 265. and i weighed like
240 my entire career oh
yeah so i was fighting i mean it's a
problem you know what's to talk about
about a heavyweight like it's insane to
me i would come in at
240 and fight a guy like ben rothwell or
levar johnson
and they're 265. 25 pounds that's what
that is
like well you're heavyweights like dude
25 pounds 25 pounds yeah
there should be a cruiserweight at 225
but there's it's only in the heavyweight
division that it's that big of a gap
well look at steep and francis there's a
big weight difference in those i don't
remember exactly how much it was but it
i mean you could see it in there
it was a lot at least 15 pounds which
yeah 15 pounds
on francis is more than 15 pounds like
tied to avasa
yeah and france is at two you know 50 or
260 of
all muscle you know [ __ ] crazy that
is yeah that's nuts
yeah nuts so i get my question for you
is
you're one of the few who decides to
retire and you're crushing the game your
vip of
the huge organization and then what like
and i'm saying this because i like you i
care about you it's like when you i
heard you're coming back i'm like
why man oh i think a lot of people had
that reaction but some people were
really excited like myself i'm obviously
excited yeah i'm not saying i'm not
excited
no i can't choose why um
there's no better answer than i just
want to like that's it that's really why
it works for me i just want to
know i just feel like i can do it and
i i made sure to go through it
you know kind of that checklist of
things before i decided to like make
that official an announcement what's the
checklist
so basically you know i have had two
kids and i wanted to make sure my body
could still do it that the sport hadn't
passed me by
that i could get in that kind of shape
that i could avoid the injury and that i
could still like
fight or flight you know they talk about
that being an instinct i mean i think
once
a fighter always a fighter but it's one
thing to think that and it's one thing
to go in there and prove it you know
especially after two kids exactly
and and you know four over four years of
being retired you know i haven't done a
ton of sparring in those four years but
i also think that's going to lead to my
longevity now
you know that i'm a little bit later in
my career i'm smarter i feel like my
body is finally connecting with
my my mindset i'm just more mature i
look at things in a different way
and um i just i so anyways the checklist
was
making sure that i could that all those
things basically sport hadn't passed me
by could i still do it could i hang
could i get on that level
could i get back into that kind of shape
was there a fight you were watching or
i'm sure you watch ufc so you watch
something like i can't beat those girls
because even me and i tell dick dude i
think i've always felt like that
like i'll watch everything yeah right
you still feel that way oh yeah yeah
if i got a chance you beat those guys
yeah certain guys yeah yeah that no that
never goes away that's right
i don't know because i don't want to
yeah but in my head i'm like i could
beat that guy
yeah did you still have fights left oh
yeah if i came back they i think i have
four fights left on my contract
got it okay so was there a fight you're
watching like i could beat her
no it just i've always felt that way
yeah but with like most
you know most all of them like i always
just feel that way but
i don't know that's part of being a
fighter i think right you got to kind of
feel that was it
yeah like i think you always got to feel
that way you know know that you can
but again i had to prove that to myself
so i went back to the gym and i started
training so it's right around the time
that i had my son so that would be about
almost 10 months ago now that's when i
had the force slow down and it was just
kind of like
everything hit a halt i knew i was done
having kids
and i was like 34. i was like now i
think
time started to become relevant i was
like i think i want to make another run
at this
and did you tell your man and your
family were they like come on so i told
my
obviously i told my man first i told
johnny i said uh
um scooter's coming up to say hi so you
got food for me
um so i told him first and i just wanted
to see what he would think because
obviously you know with the kids it's a
different
ball game like we had a lot oh yeah i
mean we have so much
it's very overwhelming at times i'm not
going to lie but i like my mom with you
i got two toddlers and
you know this weekend it's so hard i'm
home i'm not on tour and you know it's
grandma grandpa's not around just me and
my girl and we're like man what are we
gonna do
i know if the struggle is real two days
it is just us it's like we gotta figure
out
what you do like you're in it absolutely
so then
i don't know i'm not familiar with are
you married or just no we're not married
yeah so yeah get there someday so is he
is he a fighter is in your fight game
fighter
so he's fought on the ultimate fighter
before um
and now he fights for one championship
okay so he understands it
yeah yeah he understands it definitely
so
yeah he gets it he knows what's gonna
have to go into it and of course very
supportive but
he's always my rock because i'm kind of
just like
i don't know like sometimes i get these
ideas and i just
and i just i just go like i've never
been very like i have to be
you know follow this path yeah that kind
of thing it says it invades me
i'm just like fly by the seat of my
pants now i have way more structure in
my life because i have kids but i'm
still that way in my heart sure if i
feel something if i feel passionate
about it
like i'm going to go with it yeah and
that's why and i'm all in that's and
that's why the comeback was a lot more
well thought out yes exactly you know
because it's like i knew in my heart
what i wanted to do
but i'm also like you know and how my
man's like you know well we got to do
these things to make sure
like before you before you go and say
something and i didn't want to
put any pressure on myself i just want
to enjoy it i want to come back and see
like what i could do what kind of shape
i could get in and like to be honest
like
if i went in there if i got injured if i
couldn't hang if i couldn't physically
hack it then
you know i would have known and i would
have never said anything to anybody but
i'm sure you're doing pretty well in
training
right yeah you're a little beast yeah so
so then uh when you told one
championship we're like oh come on
because they know you're probably not
gonna be able to i don't know if that's
the way
yeah i don't know if that's the way that
they felt but they but that's not what
they said like when i talked to cha
tree who is the ceo and founder of one
championship he was
he was 100 supportive like it's not it's
not very often you find a friend in the
business world that
has you know that your dreams are going
to kind of
counter in in a way what would be
beneficial to them but they're still
going to support
you in that mission you know again my
point with one championship
like you said they're they're supportive
of it is like what's good for you is
good for them like the bigger me should
take kids
right associate one championship but in
the vps yeah for them
exactly but i had to put in my 30 days
so
ufc right yeah so i've got like maybe
two weeks left
and then then you can always go back i'm
sure like the doors open i think so
i mean we left on amicable terms they've
been really good to me i had a good
experience there
like i have no no you know
i mean i don't know which direction i'm
not you know i'm not promising anything
i don't know if i'll continue to work
with the ufc after i'm done fighting or
if i'll go back to one championship but
i think doors are open either way
which is just nice to have options and
then uh
is there any opponents in mind or
because i did did i read that your your
your first life's gonna be at 45 so is
that the plan
no so it originally i thought about it
because like i'm still breastfeeding my
son
and everything like that and i was like
i don't have to diet and cut weight and
like worry about
you know milk supply and all that stuff
but um
i wanted options when i started to look
at the 145 pound division
it's like they let they just let meegan
anderson go now there's two women
and amanda's coming back down to 135.
that division i mean there's nothing
there
you know what i mean so it's like
felicia spencer and danielle wolff
are fighting but daniel wolf is like i
don't know she's like one or two fights
in mma
not very much i think she's like 101 or
want to know or something
and then there's felicia which i think
would be a great fight i would love to
maybe fight her someday but yeah
i mean if we're not going to have a
division with fights to keep me busy no
longevity there
so you beat felicia what are you going
to do that's what i guess they maybe
amanda nunes if she wants to do it
yeah but you know to be honest i've been
out for four and a half years like
i don't think amanda for my second fight
would be a very smart decision
you know what i mean she's a total
badass and it's great i want to fight
her again but
i want to make sure i do things the
right way and give myself the best
opportunity to win and i don't think
jumping in off
one fight is the best thing to do but
you're such a big name too so it puts
ufc in a tough spot because it's not
like they just toss you some newbie you
know
like calling home was like i'm down for
that like all these dogs because
you're a big dog in the space you're you
know you know the mountain rush more
female fighting so all of them want
their shot at michael tate now i know
it's funny actually i've been hearing a
lot of but i mean that's great i'll be
the second most hunted woman in the
division
you know there'll be amanda and it'll be
me yup and she doesn't do
tune-up fights though like like boxing
you come out for your life
there's no tune-up they don't they don't
play that it's very it's sink or swim
very much so smashy for misha yeah
because you know what
big long career like literally she's one
of the most famous female fighters of
all time so
they're not gonna damn they're not gonna
go they're gonna give it right like you
know what i mean
i'm not making a comparison to miesha
but you look at like even with cm punk
like have fun dude and he just never
fought before she got absolutely
destroyed
yeah can we get him a newer guy
he'll figure it out and they're like and
if he doesn't he doesn't
it's it's literally synchronicity they
want everybody tried and true i mean
they don't want to
build up records and have people be i
don't know that's
34 years old two kids in four year
layoff and you go in there with the
shorts
yeah basically and you're ready yeah
absolutely i mean that's i gotta be
that's fine yeah yeah so my
so the first woman that i'm that i'm
scheduled to fight is maureen renau are
you familiar with her yes
yeah okay no it's not an easy fight
bring her up chin no it's not easy it's
not
she she so this is what this is what
is um
she's coming off losses correct she is
so that's the worst part about this is
she's a lot better than what her record
says
in my opinion so she has four losses but
they're all
wait no close decisions she's never been
finished
she's lost split decision she's been on
the verge of being a contender
a number of times she's finished jessica
andraj which is like
impossible to do she triangle choked her
then she hurt
uh sarah mcmahon on the feet and
triangle choked sarah mcmahon
that's not easy to triangle choke you
know what i mean it's like so she's got
these
wins that's a weird fight huh because
it's yeah i guess people like yo should
come out four losses good
for what i mean it's like kind of like
easy it's not office
it's a it's not like it's kind of like
worries me because i'm like people
really look at that and they're just
gonna see a wreck and be like oh four
losses i'm like i don't look at that
at all that way no those losses were all
decision losses and they were pretty
close like
she held her own like she never was in
major trouble she's never been in major
trouble
she's never been finished she's never
been like knocked down like she's never
she's tough she's durable she can do
everything she's a black belt in jiu
jitsu she can strike
you know she can re she can clinch
wrestle um
and when's that fight so let's go down
yeah july 17th
oh that's wrong yeah you got time yeah
yeah i mean
i got time because i've been doing this
uh i've been training for you know
months now so
and then did your manager call the ufc
say come back or did you handle that
no i did i actually was like bugging
dana on instagram and i have no idea why
but he blew off like my first five dms
about wanting to come back just didn't
see him
no he saw them that's why he didn't
respond he didn't respond
that's why i messaged him on instagram
because i'm like i'll be able to see if
he read it you know
like i wanted to know like i wasn't
gonna send like just a text message
like i want to know he saw that [ __ ]
were you nervous when you uh dm'd him
kinda but then i saw and then i got i
started to be like maybe someone else is
running his account
you know you never know like maybe
someone else thought he's in it on
social media
but i was like maybe i don't know maybe
there's a person that's checking it or
you know helps him out with some things
and they opened it and he didn't
actually see i was trying to make up
excuses but deep down i really knew he
just was like
ignoring me he probably was like oh
she's not serious that's what i want
that's what i think
she's fine in one championship yeah and
then what what what got over the hump
where he started engaging with you
so through dm or text no it's all
through
instagram so i wrote this long message
and i was like look i'm not gonna come
back to the us and move my family back
and you know
you know leave one championship is what
i really look like i probably would have
to do right that's what i was
assuming would happen i'm not going to
do that jump from one tree until i have
another
to make sure so where you know where are
we at with this i want to fight and then
he just said come home
that's all he said in just two weeks oh
damn that's pretty gangster but i know
right
but i kind of took that as like put your
money where your mouth is like if you're
really serious about wanting to fight
and prove yourself that's absolutely
dance that makes sense
yeah i'm sure he's blown up all the time
yeah it's all right move home let's see
what happens
yeah so i did good you're like yeah i'm
here dude exactly all right we'll get
you a fight then i came into the office
and he's like so what are you doing here
i was like
what do you mean he's like what do you
want i was like i want to [ __ ] fight
yeah
like that's what i want to do i came
home i know right
here i am and he just still was kind of
like
okay like he was still kind of like you
know why he's like are you not making
good money i think that was the other
thing maybe he was concerned about me
being desperate
right that it washed up misha tate was
gonna come back and desperate to feed
her family kind of thing and just
get my ass kicked and take a paycheck
and leave you know
um but i was like no i really want to
fight i was like okay well wait what i
was like probably 45 so i don't have to
worry about cutting weight or just walk
in fat and happy
and he was like okay um
what did he say he said well oh he said
45 is a rematch with amanda and i said
so is 35.
like either way i'm going to get to it
you know what i mean so
i just uh i was like that's fine with me
that's what i want anyways at the end of
the day like i want to fight her again i
want to
i want to do it i want to be the baddest
woman on the planet again and then
the since you left you know especially
four years ago that 35 is stacked
it's a bit of a difference it is well it
is but a lot of the women that
when i left are still on the top so
that's why another reason why i
definitely don't feel like
you know the sports like quote unquote
passed me by i mean holly you've seen
her get a you know numerous title shots
again she's still
talking about wanting to make another
run at it i mean juliana pena
we grew up in this sport together she's
going to fight you know for the title
next like
a lot of the women marion renault right
this is her retirement fight
granted but i mean she's been in the ufc
close to as long as i have um
i would say cats and gano obviously she
went over to bellator but she's still in
it she's still winning fights right
these are women that cyborg amanda
amanda too you know
to be honest yeah i mean yeah she's so
she's come back like crazy
yeah but those are all women that were
in my in a better in my ears
you know she's been around forever holly
holm doing this sarah mcmahon
pena mcmahon yeah
yeah they're all kind of doing it so you
know it's a it's a good mixture but a
lot of them are still from my what i
would consider my generation of fighting
and they're still doing great things and
still holding top five spots and
top ten spots mostly all of them
actually um
so yeah i definitely think like i still
have time and was there any
uh idea or was there any attempt to get
released from the ufc contract so you
can find them one championship just make
it easy
well i think this is route yeah that
would have been the easiest route but i
knew that they weren't going to do that
just based on we tried to do a grappling
match with one championship
and they ex-nade that real quick dana
didn't like that you're too
you're too big of a name yeah so i guess
i mean that's what it is
and to be fair like the uf the ufc had
so much to do with
elevating my brand correct you know i
think people cared a little bit coming
from strikeforce you know ron and i had
that great fight it's what and
and you know gina and cyborg since that
time kind of moved forward and it was a
big part of that movement i think people
started to care about it but
it was still a lot of hardcore fans you
know hardcore fans really cared it
wasn't so
much like it is now mainstream yeah when
i think of
uh women's fighting you talk about the
pioneers it's like gina
cyborg rhonda and you and then amanda
you know came on late and obviously
she's the dominant face of the
woman's fighting all women's fighting so
there's like you five are in mount
rushmore
yeah and you know amanda i don't think
she was too much behind us though you
know she's i think she's 32.
but she just didn't get noticed until
she
changed camps and then changed camp than
the maturity right like
you look at that fight with cats in
ghana right she
got tired and then got beat and i think
she learned from that and now she's just
this
absolute dominant champ man yeah
dominant and she's i think
for you and your advantages you knew her
before that these girls find her now
like meegan and stuff like that you know
they see her as this
the goat the lion you don't see that no
i'm just like no that's
i've see i've seen him i've seen her
exactly and i've seen her losing an
invicta i oh sarah deleglio i'm pretty
sure it was sarah delegato beat her but
uh
um yeah i've seen her lose before i mean
i know she has her weaknesses and stuff
which i think is
such a big advantage because a lot of
those girls like you know i love mikaner
so i think she was beat before it even
started
i agree completely agree she looked like
her eyes got like this big as soon as
the bell went and amanda started
marching across the way and she was just
kind of like ah
and i was like well i will not be like
ah when i fight her i promise you
that i can't i can't promise victory you
guys but i can always promise that i'll
bring a hell of a fight and i'm not
scared of any woman on this planet
is there besides her is there any other
fights redemption fights or anything
like that you're looking for
um i wish i could run it back again with
kat but
she's over in bellator right now so
that's kind of just a great fight
yeah i would really like to um to run it
back with that
um you know and then i i think i'll end
up fighting holly again it's not really
something i'm like gunning down because
i beat holly so it's not
like you know you know like gotta have
it but i'm sure she'll be one of those
six fights though yeah
i'm sure she will be at some point i'd
love to fight jermaine that's one that
i've never
i never got the opportunity to fight her
so i'm pretty sure you're gonna you're
gonna win this one then
you're looking at those those top top
women exactly you're looking at you know
top three and i think jermaine is yeah
she's one she's one holly holm's two
i'm interested in yana too cause i think
yana and jermaine
those would be fun fights for me those
women are both
you know ranked really high and and um
you know giannis she's improving every
fight that i see her she's getting
better
yeah she's getting a lot better she's
got good striking she you know she's
fought cyborg so i know she's not scared
you know she's not scared
to fight people and she comes to fight
she gets better with her wrestling been
seeing her take people down and
you know land her ground and kind of
stuff so i think that'd be a good one
too and then i was reading too
uh before you came in here you were
you're struggling with some mental
health issues is that right
yeah i was like uh i was just struggling
just because you're in singapore you
think
yeah that was so no this was a long time
this was a
really throughout my entire career but
it kind of came to a headway
i would say um it really
started to get bad before the holly
fight to be honest and then
during camp you're like where were we
telling like straight depression or you
just didn't want to do it anymore
what's going on there yeah so i had
struggled a lot in my personal life
so with my ex um it was just not a it
was just a very toxic relationship to be
honest
it's tough to do that it's hard it's
hard and then fighting
yeah and especially when that person is
your head coach
oh [ __ ] yeah
i know you and i are just like taking
off on this conversation these two are
like what is going on right now we're
trying to follow this
alex also when's your next boxing fight
so you got a box over there it's like
you won the fighters huh
he's like so you play for the la sparks
your point guard for the la sports and
you get ranked right
you guys should be paid more i'm trying
to say i got a business i'm new to the
fighting world i'm new to it
yeah you surprised me though yeah so it
was toxic you're dealing with you know
your head coach and he's your boyfriend
which is a knife
that was a nightmare because there was
no break you know obviously the personal
part of the relationship goes into the
gym a little bit
i'd say we did a better job of
separating it there but coming
you know back home the other way it was
like almost never separated you know so
it was just like constant pressure
and to be honest like you just uh i
don't know it was like almost nine years
that we were together and i tried to
exit that relationship probably
you know the last four or five of it at
least fifty percent
your head coach it's like no it's one
and yeah i mean and so that took a toll
on you
yeah you know you would threaten me in
ways too that was just like you you just
don't feel like i could leave there's no
excuse on my part but i mean i can't
make excuses i can't blame him i have to
take accountability and blame for myself
because ultimately at the end of the day
it's my decision but
you know when somebody is threatening to
like take their own life
or you know release nude photos
things like that you know you're just
like oh okay
you know i think what's good for people
let's do is like so many people when
they're in toxic relationships everyone
goes
won't you just leave them and you're a
badass so i'm sure a lot of girls like
misha yeah i just get out struggled i
struggled for a long time like
you know we get into arguments and i'd
want to like walk away and get my space
keep my cool because i'm not somebody
who likes to lose my cool if i'm getting
to the point where i feel like i'm going
to say some [ __ ] i don't mean
walk away i want to walk away i want to
take a deep breath i want to calm down
you know
i don't like to stay in the heat of that
moment and he's like wanted to hash it
out right then and there you know so
like
it would be like sometimes like blocking
me in a room like not letting me exit
the room like things like that and those
things just wearing you mentally because
also feel like you beat him up but
that's a different conversation
right you kind of think he's a small guy
but be honest
he found the ufc too you know what i
mean he was just like he was tough like
he's a very
you know good wrestler good grappler
good you know so i mean still feel like
if
vegas odds you're like minus one i've
been in enough i'm just saying if i was
it if i was the ref
if i was her dean in the house i'd be
like i got misha
yeah but it's hard to think logically
through all that
especially and then you're fighting
grown women in steel cage yeah you got
to deal with that
what was your breaking point like if you
don't mind me asking like yeah
the breaking point really was probably
with the amanda fight when i um
i just felt like as i became more
successful he just kind of like
relaxed and uh you know i hate to use
the term writing coattails or whatever
but that's i mean look back on i don't
know how to draw a better analogy
he just kind of started to fight less
control did less and
started to be such a major detractor for
what i was trying to do it was like
we made it you know you go out there and
fight i'm just gonna chill here i'm
gonna go
drink and i'm gonna party at night while
you're trying to sleep for your training
camp and i'm gonna stay up and be loud
as [ __ ] downstairs and
not be around you know not be there in
the ways that were supporting me so to
be like i remember just being so
frustrated like i'm trying to sleep
shut up you know he's like downstairs
drinking beer and partying with his
friends and i'm like
oh i was so frustrated that whole camp
and just the emotional breakdown that
you get to a point where there's so much
pressure on you to do one thing but then
there's like just awful pressure in the
relationship too that's just not
working for you so there's affecting
your mental health
yeah she showed up to my wake up with
amanda late and intoxicated oh you got
fire
you got a fire i suck at firing people
too but i mean people get
put in cruise control like everyone gets
comfortable and it's just comfortable
and then he brought like a bunch of
people with him
like i don't know he felt like he was
the star yeah 100 percent
yeah he brought all these people with
him it was just toxic but then did you
suffer from depression before
any of this or did that in spouts for
sure
but i think i'm a pretty mentally strong
person so i always would find a way to
kind of like go
get through it you know and i know
understand that depressions for some
people can be like it's just never gone
for me it was in in parts so there
wouldn't it wasn't bad all the time
right there's great moments you want to
fight that's a great moment you
persevere you great moment you had a
great practice you feel good
birthday you know whatever you feel good
for that moment but eventually it just
started to consume me it was like
it's like poison you know it was just
like i just kept drinking poison until i
felt like
i was just i couldn't do it anymore and
then was there a point where you're
warming up for the fight in the
in the back there in the in the locker
room warming up before a big fight being
like what am i doing man
yep absolutely yeah yeah that was the
amanda fight i felt very flat in that
fight
and then your coaches can notice yeah
for sure because i've had fights around
my coaches like what's up with you i'm
like i just don't feel like doing this
man how about that
yep like what you fighting out like yeah
i know
i don't feel like doing it right now i'm
a human man i don't feel like doing this
right now absolutely
you don't have a choice i'm like yeah i
know yeah i don't have a choice you
gotta go there
yep yep so you feel like that it's a
nightmare you've been here because that
guy is ready to go and it's the biggest
fight your life but
for whatever if they if you get to just
push this till tomorrow i'd be better
like tomorrow i'm probably going to be
feeling better for right now i just
don't feel like doing this
i remember hitting miss my god i don't
feel like doing this right yeah you ever
see the lion eat their trainer one
breaking point
it's like that it's just like you're
just like i don't feel like [ __ ]
doing this right
now like i just stopped not right now
having a bad day tough
women a bad moment yeah so you're tough
for everyone
yeah yeah yeah men are women it's just
not what men and women deal with
so it was just that specific moment
right there you're like i don't want to
[ __ ] do this
uh for me it happened it was there a
fight and then roy nelson
got it and my team could tell they're
like dude come on or even the travis
brown when i'm warming up i was like
this is it
like no don't talk like i'm like dude
i'm [ __ ] telling you
this is it man i don't want you to felt
it yeah i have other [ __ ] to do
like well let's not think about that
right i'm like i know i just want you
know before we go this is right before
we're arguing like i want you to know we
will never do this again like no you're
just saying that like
all right dude let me get it back i'm
like i'm done how many times
how clear can i make it people just
think you're emotional in that situation
like when i retired too it's like oh
she's just emotional but i was really
serious about that
when it clicks it clicks for fun and i
didn't i don't
even remember my warm-up to be honest
with raquel i was in such a funk i was
in such a just an
overwhelming depression at that time
it's like that time in my life is like
is a blur to be honest with you i don't
remember it i don't remember very much
about
any of that the week of like none of it
i was just in a i was just not
i was not even there i don't know how to
explain it and the same thing when i
went in the fights like i wasn't there
and i just
this is why i didn't know i was going to
retire people ask me that did you know
you were going to retire that night
no because it had been that way for me
so many times in my fights before where
there was a lot of [ __ ] that was going
wrong you know
arguments um lack of support you know
isolation from my family and things i i
just didn't have
the will to battle that anymore and
eventually i
reached a point where i was like i can't
i can't do it anymore but i didn't
realize that until the fight happened
because every time before that i was
always able to turn it on anyways
overcome no matter what
yeah exactly you know just like you just
do it anyways
just in spite of this is part of the
process this is how you get ready and
then you get to a point where you're
just
you're you have nothing left there's not
even like nothing to light a match with
did you know what in the fight
that's the worst feeling like yeah in
the fight like immediately i was like
yeah
like
yeah you're probably right i get it i
see his big ass i'm moving like
the [ __ ] am i doing i do not want to do
this
yeah you're like looking at the what the
ladies wearing in the audience you're
like
yeah yeah you know like well you guys
are so [ __ ] big
wait so you remember we were i didn't
ask you because i remember we were going
to clinch up against the cage or
whatever and i was like maybe i could
just hang on here for the rest of the
year
i don't want to do anything and she
starts hitting me in the face i'm like
come on i'm not even doing anything to
you i'm just like
trying to give you the love you know
like and it was just we so
i laugh about it now but at the time i
was like this is that is the worst
feeling in the world no
yes it's so embarrassing i remember
being in the clinch with our love skin
just be like
can we just waste time and stay here
stay here can we and
fans are booing i'm like i don't give a
[ __ ]
let's just stay here dude you're
coachella you gotta do this
like let's just stay here for the five
minutes well you gotta be this is
[ __ ] intense
it's intense it's [ __ ] insane no i
was gonna ask so were you
were you with him until you retired the
whole day
so he broke up like right after the
fight with amanda which was my second to
last fight
okay yeah and then try to do kind of
just the coaching thing but that was
he just you know didn't want that and so
there's a ton of extra pressure in that
department too
you know so the weight fully wasn't off
your shoulders no
yeah not at all and i think how great
this comeback's gonna be because you're
not dealing with all that [ __ ] yeah
that's what i'm so excited now you got
that mama beer instinct yeah
which is a completely different it is
extra strength right there fighting for
my family
you know it's different it's not just me
and and um
you know i'm doing it because i really
really want to i have to obviously put
put my needs and desires first
in a way but you're absolutely right
when you have more to just kind of
motivate you or to fight for
it's different it's different it's
different yeah
yeah absolutely you enjoy being a mom i
love being a mom yeah mom's being a
mom's crazy it's
it's the hardest thing i've ever done to
be honest like it every
everyday grind i think it's good for
fighters and entertainers because
as a fighter entertainer you're always
like never stop and smell the roses you
always what the next thing the next
thing yeah with kids you have to be in
the moment and present at all times
yeah otherwise they're gonna fall in the
pool or [ __ ] take a knife down the
throat like you gotta be present
like i don't have time to sit and think
about my next practice a lot of times
my overthink my fight or my opponent is
like i have those dedicated times for
that and the rest of time is like
it's the kids like they come first
really yeah but i love it
because the one thing it's so refreshing
i don't know how i could ever have a bad
day when my daughter
she runs into our room and she just
mommy daddy i said
i slept one i had a dream that i was on
the moon
and i didn't have any blankets and she
said what about my morning kiss and she
just
you know she gives me those hugs and
kisses and it's like my god i'm blessed
that's why i want a bun i'm so blessed
too but i want to buy an alarm dude all
the love yeah i just want to walk
a lot of kids i was born to be a dad i
absolutely love it
like yesterday for an hour but by a
fireplace they're playing hide and go
seek i just stayed there and watched
them for an hour i'm like i can't
believe they're so into this [ __ ]
chase my daughter loves it my my son
will be old enough soon i think he's
starting to like walk around with those
walker things
he's 10 months so he's getting he's
getting there i think a little you know
around that first birthday and you know
a little after that they'll actually be
able to start really playing with each
other because like right now they're
just
uh she's almost three and he's almost
one yeah right
yeah yeah and would you want your kids
to be fighters
would i want them to be no going to the
field because obviously their papa's a
fighter their mom is one of the greats
yeah no i wouldn't i wouldn't pick it
because i know it's a hard
it's a hard sport it's a hard life it's
unforgiving it's definitely tough but
if they want to be i'll support them and
i'll just do my best to make sure that
they're the best
yeah and the safest they can be you know
that's all that all i want for my
children is to have
big dreams i want them to not set
limitations on themselves and i want
them to go for whatever it is that sets
their heart on fire that's that's
apparent i just want them to be
passionate about something i don't give
a [ __ ] with
video games art music whatever it is
i feel like find your passion run with
it's not human nature to not be
passionate
i don't believe anyways i think it's
human nature be passionate i did think
that it's also human nature to second
guess yourself though and not
go for it to be too timid to go for what
you're passionate but i'd say most
people are too timid
or too scared to fail yeah i don't want
like dude but there's you're always
gonna have
something that you just love or
gravitate towards you know to me that's
pat
you know that's passion because people
just don't feed into that sometimes
they're scared of like no what if
that's weird and they don't go peter's
in the youtube commenters right they're
never too scared to chase their dreams
so they go for people like you and me
exactly that's what you get let's do
some current events jen oh before we go
there let me ask you a question
um karisa shields right
great shields yeah we call it t-rex all
right
t-rex is one of she won't dip her toes
in the ufc
because she said she's there's no
competition in boxing how do you feel
about that
no [ __ ] can i answer this for you yeah
misha would beat the [ __ ] out of your
clarissa shields
she would take her down and choke her
out she got a nice one too i don't care
dude
you've never seen mischa fighting i
think you take her down and choke her
out choke it up
yeah how about how big well it's uneven
because you know i'm looking at you
great body great form she's easy she's
she's
bluff though yeah but you got to know
how to use that weight
that's what matters like it's a
different ball game and different like
range for boxing but you know
they're not used to having to deal with
somebody grabbing them
and putting them in places they don't
want the referee always steps in and the
difference
is different too like you'll see like
for example connor when he fought
doesn't worry this last one we lost with
the leg kicks yeah yeah he's been so
heavy in the boxing he he was so heavy
on his feet
forgot oh dude we just don't box here
and so the distance is different
even connor who's a master of mixed
martial arts he's been so focused on
boxing
he figured out the legs lots of leg
kicks so with clarissa she's never
fought before
i'm sure she's gonna get to the ufc
hopefully they do it right
and if they start tossing her they're
not gonna give her a girl like misha
tate right away
they give her like someone like what
yeah but eventually she's going to run
into oh
yeah she's starting off in the pfl right
yeah yeah
which is great and some poor girl who
thinks she's a striker is going to get
her [ __ ] face knocked off because i
wouldn't want to be on any of her
punches
she beat everybody up in here separation
yeah yeah she's a monster oh yeah she's
definitely a hard hitter
i think she will make a great transition
to mma because she's
you know for sure ultra aggressive and
she's a good athlete she's good
instincts you know so when you start
teaching her the right things i think
she'll she'll pick it up fast
you know she's a big strong woman but i
think i mean
i would say 9.9 times out of 10 like a
an mma fighter will destroy
a straight boxer like almost all mma
fighters all the time
there's just so many different ways yeah
so many different boxing is such a small
part of what we do
and even everything that works for
boxing doesn't work for mma so it's not
even like
the best boxer in the world could just
come over and and
and not worry about getting kicked in
the head like they can't slip a punch
like that like they do in boxing or roll
and they get neat in the face like it
just doesn't work or even you think
about the gloves like boxers cover up
like this
you cover like this in mma with those
small gloves even if i'm hitting you
it's still it's getting
it's still hurting yeah it's not padding
it's not gone and it'll and those those
punches will slip through
somewhere like 100 if you're blocked
here they're coming in the middle if
you're blocked here they're they're
they're going to hit you on the side
just a bit of a different animal yeah
the range is totally totally different i
just got so much insight
but i'm a big fan of hers though
i do think she's going to come over and
make some huge waves and
if she can i know she's working with
jackson so with her athletic ability and
the way she picks things up
yeah if she does get that sprawling
brawl down it's going to be problems so
jimmy knocking girls down so do you see
her as a striker and a grappler
do you see her she's not a grappler it's
just not in her wheelhouse no
she's always going to be predominantly
striker she just needs to learn how to
sprawl and brawl
yeah she's going to be chuckled she got
to learn how to prevent the prevent the
takedown
dude it's problems okay yep this is my
first time hearing like the ins and outs
because i've never heard you really
talk about your fighting like i really
stay away from him
food truck or no that's it was pretty
cool like hearing like the
back and forth like the inside i'm like
yeah oh [ __ ] this world is intense
and i don't think you guys realize how
much b she is yeah yeah she's trying to
goad it yeah 100
i saw with holly holmes i was like get
up holly
you're rooting for holly you son of a
[ __ ]
i didn't she just knocked out ronda
rousey never again i was like i'm sorry
ever again
hell with holly i called misha all right
what do you got
this episode with misha tate on fighter
and the kids is brought to you by
audit on it freaking supplements man the
summer's coming
and don't panic because there's still
time to get your diet right and get your
nutrients right and get your freaking
supplements right but you can only do it
with the best so do it with
on it on it.com fighter 10 off whatever
you need man
we got protein powder we got joint oil
we got frickin shroom tech
creatine all right we got a keto
collection we got coffee for your ass
maybe you're on a strict diet you need
everything you can get man
whey protein protein based protein
protein bars protein bites
like i told you coffee how about you
want to snack your fat ass on a snack
you want some protein power puffs some
fat butter elk bars warrior bars
eat on up thickies go to onit.com
fighter for 10 off
where'd scooter go he's at home oh he's
chilling he's right here just chilling
just hanging out this is a very sad one
um
has passed away this morning there was a
little bit of controversy
yesterday the night before because there
were several celebrities who came out
who were mutual fr
who were friends of his saying r.i.p
we're so sorry you're gone
but his family hadn't announced anything
yet and so they actually pulled it down
i think it was the
uh it was kailani it was uh lunell
they posted r.i.p like dmx is gone they
pulled
that post down very quickly just out of
respect for the family i think because
they wanted to wait for the family yeah
because the family hadn't confirmed
anything
and there was uh i believe it was his
manager of the past three years came out
and said
hey he's actually still alive he is
currently on
uh life support but his organs are
deteriorating and kind of starting to
give up on him
so right now we're kind of trying to
decide from an overdose
it was from an overdose they still
haven't um confirmed which drug
it is but they're saying it's an
overdose so this morning
they announced that he passed away what
was your first dmx song you heard
god
uh what was the video with him and all
the pit bulls going to give you oh
that's the rough riders and no
rough riders are anthem first when he
had the pit bulls and the uh
four wheels yeah the four wheels mm-hmm
what about you what was your favorite
dog get at me dawg that's a great oh you
know i had what was the album where he's
covered in blood
oh uh hell is uh hell is hot uh i
thought it was blood flushing my flesh
blood on my butt oh
you're right i'm sorry he was always
covered in blood
because he messed me up with the post
but i'm sorry misha do you know dmx
yeah a little but i'm not a huge music
buff or whatever but
just in general so don't don't quiz me
too hard
favorite member of rough rider besides
dmx
[Applause]
that's what he's most known well known
for right before what a party
yeah what what in singapore were you
watching tv out there
was it weird [ __ ] i don't i don't really
watch tv but
johnny does he always has that damn
thing on if it was my house i would have
no tvs in my house i don't care about tv
at all
is your three-year-old into ipads yet i
battle it
i battle it so hard well you know what
we did he he can't have it monday
through friday but on the weekends he
can have there you go that's perfect
i mostly do what about tv though do that
watch tv
tv he watches some tv but usually like
he won't sit down my five-year-old he
won't sit down long enough to watch a
show but
if he's if i like wear him out like he
has swim lessons you know school yeah
you know we'll play basketball if he's
worn out or a hike or something
they don't chill and watch like little
rascals or like a movie
they watch a lot of music videos like
youtube music videos like that's
like they're obsessed with bts and like
katy perry and
dosha cat five
that's what he's into wow i know i don't
think i was
at five years old we're so advanced i
know they know the dances and [ __ ]
my daughter she's like outgrowing cocoa
melon but she's into you know like those
little like those little
shows or whatever you know yeah i don't
love it like bubble guppies
yeah i think that one well it was the
song is blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah
guppies yeah
so then the the head fish she'll be like
so if you're gonna eat spaghetti
would you eat it with a fork or
a cup of water oh so it's like come on
i'm like come on this is
stupid and then tyler's like yeah this
is stupid
so it's like sesame street how do they
like teach yeah basically that's why
it's mickey mouse
my son we got really into rick and morty
together which is a little it's a
definitely adult show yeah like his
favorite episodes like pickle rick
you watch that's so violent it is for
five-year-olds
i know you said you were born to be a
dad
but that's how that's how i was raised
that's how i was raised like i was
playing mortal kombat at five
down yeah i turned out normal all right
what else
pretty normal what else you got jen
there you go okay uh
do you know anything about this sure do
you okay dressing is [ __ ]
yeah former players i know
depression check out these mental health
is important
um so heartwarming stories yeah former
nfl player philip
adams uh killed five people and then
killed himself
yeah and so the backstory here he played
in the nfl he's kind of like a
journeyman nfl bounce around six
different teams and then the doctor he
killed the doctor took him off
medication and wouldn't refill his
medication so he went basically crazy
and then went to the house shot both of
the guys work on the ac unit
it makes no sense they had nothing to do
with it and then shot the
grandfather the grandmother and the two
grandchildren
and then and then killed himself but not
the doctor
uh the grandfather was the doctor oh the
grandfather was a doctor but because he
couldn't get his medication but i think
he went crazy yeah was he suffering from
cte
they're gonna blame it on that but it
sounds like he was just a [ __ ] an
idiot and then hat needed this
medication that's a health issue yeah
his dad did say like football messed
them up yeah like i think they will i
i'm gonna go to that every time but also
you know how many football players
played football and aren't pieces of
[ __ ] like this
i should say don't need this medication
like the odds are you can be fine
playing football or fighting but there
are some outliers
but my problem is this is oh ct no no he
can't just be a piece of [ __ ] yeah
and maybe he was off some medication
like yeah he wasn't invited but i also
think there might be a time when we
start to understand mental health and a
whole different
like level of it because i think we we
look at it like we think we understand
but i just think we might start to
understand the science behind it like
for instance you know how barbaric i
feel like sea world and like captivating
those animals and
the [ __ ] like that is like you start to
understand like how in-depth they are
like it's gonna look like it's gonna
look worse i think in the future as we
start to even understand
more so and i think the same thing with
mental health i think as if we really
can start to understand what's actually
going on in someone's brain
like what's really going on in there
like we all look at it like level head
and to be like oh it's a piece of [ __ ]
and i'm not saying he's not definitely
not making any argument for him but if
we
start to maybe really understand like
holy [ __ ] be able to look in someone's
brain like that's what your brain's
doing and
like that's that's what their brain's
doing like whoa
like medication yeah didn't i look at
robin williams brain
yes right and they said there was a
bunch of wild things up in there
yeah yeah and there's like something
like after certain areas get like
atrophied you know that don't get
um yeah so like it can throw off all
your hormone production and that's also
cute that can make you crazy i'm not
saying it can make like you like that
but i mean
maybe i mean off your meds you don't
know how a person will react
yeah and not even like just the men's
just like how his what is going on in
his brain like how do we help people in
that situation like i don't know
like i i don't know i think there will
come a point when we start to understand
it on a whole different level
the way we treat prisoners like the way
you just put them you know putting
solitary confinement
like that they think in like 30 years
when i look back the way we treat prison
like what the [ __ ] are we doing
yeah because you're not prison was
supposed to be for rehabilitation
no one's being rehabilitated they're
going [ __ ] crazy
and they're worse when they get out so
obviously it's not working but it's
making the state a ton of money so they
keep putting people in
so it's crazy but i think the biggest
thing with mental illness that they're
going to find in
probably 10 years is cell phones social
media and the way it affects the the
younger population
it's a drug with the bullying as long as
i can but it's really tough because it's
very addicting and it's like then you
have to be the example too you can't be
on it but our lives are dictated by this
too
like i'm not gonna lie i'm addicted to
my phone too i try to moderate but
there's so much i have to do on my phone
and then you just sucked into it it's
like a black hole
they call the cell phones the new
cigarette well they they said iphone's
going to come with that
that warning like a cigarette saying
this is an addictive product eventually
oh [ __ ] yeah seriously it makes sense it
won't matter well do you think of think
you think how discipline you are
take joe rogan for example one of the
most discipli this discipline people you
know even he'll admit he's addicted his
phone
like the most disappointed people you
know and they're addicted to that thing
it's a [ __ ] problem yeah yeah
you gotta be a real beast because this
is the thing about it is though is that
there's no like see i already have all
my stuff pulled up even
right it's like i'm ready to go you ever
notice like sometimes you pull up your
phone and you're going to do something
and then like you see your instagram and
you just have to
you just have you just do it like you
don't even mean to like because the way
your brain works is it's a in the way
they set up social media with twitter
and instagram it's a dopamine that's
released when you see mentions or
comments stuff like that there's a
dopamine so
naturally your body likes that feeling
so it goes to that
right but then you expend way too much
and you don't have it left for like your
kids you know your kids do something
cute and you're like
i mean that's that's a problem right i
mean i'm this thing that happens very
much to me it's not a problem for me
because i
i i really don't [ __ ] with it at all i
post i get out
i post what i need yeah that's amazing i
don't see anything
so i have no idea what you've been up to
i have no idea if they post something
dope
i don't find out fight announcements so
i'm like at starbucks and a fan like
dude
misha is back that's how i found out
starbucks why do you find out about all
this stuff
what do you mean you were like she's
like have you heard about this story so
we were all like no
you're like i did well no not world star
i read news like
if i'm if i'm on my phone i'm reading
right i'm not on social that's the thing
is like it just i don't know it just
still like i feel like it just sucks me
in
no it doesn't do i
because you know every sunday they give
you like the hours and stuff like how
much you oh it tells you it tells you
exactly what you're
sending me you boys are on your phone
when we go on the road you go the green
room everyone's naked
i journal a lot not in the green room
i text my nose all the time no am i not
you haven't read my notes
you journal you you journal when we're
on the road in the green in the green
room bro in my notes that's how i get to
my journal i journal
down all my thoughts have you ever seen
this man
are you looking at my notes are you
looking at my phone have you ever you
know one time one time i promise you you
want to read my notes and i seen you one
time i seen him on his phone looking at
no so y'all both do it
you're talking about my stand-up notes
yeah yeah yeah you're telling me you're
not on instagram in the green room i
don't [ __ ] with instagram like that
get the [ __ ] out of your bra to be with
you but god damn no
i i do [ __ ] with instagram but a lot of
times yeah a lot of it's just notes that
i drop
and i'd take it to my journal we're not
we're in naples next week
on saturday we'll look at your phone and
say what you've been doing okay what
would you do
check that out that's because because i
collected all the whenever i go on the
road i collect
all my conscious of like not being on
this phone no i'm not worried about that
it will still show his social media so
so what kind of content do you post on
there
on youtube well this this is how i sell
tickets or get views from my show so
it's usually
clips from my shows or videos you have
someone else make it for you and then
you just go on there and like yeah and
you just post it post it
i see nothing i see nothing do you
follow anybody
i i do on instagram but i'm i don't view
it i don't view it
i literally post and get out yeah i used
to follow people and that's how i keep
up my friends who don't live here so i'm
like that right now
i should call them like a normal [ __ ]
human being people understand like how
hard that is so what do you do
what do you what do you do for your your
down time because that's like my like
guilty pleasure and i like i'll
go and yeah also just surf on instagram
or whatever you know once the kids are
asleep for a little bit like
what do you do then read a book either
read or i'm with my kid like when i get
when i walk in the door it's game on
for sure but like once the kids are
asleep like watch tv
am i going to watch tv we'll make sure
you don't watch different things yeah
there you go so if you're just
sitting around you know yeah yeah
there's some good tv shows out there
it's a lot of great
i mean i have nothing right now i've
watched everything you've been a while
you better go on snowfall
have you watched uh have you watched uh
the handmaid's tale
i have oh on netflix that's a good one i
like that one anyways
yeah it's good though it's really good
that's good i mean i really liked it
i don't get that much into shows or
whatever but that's fun it's really good
huge show huge show like all the awards
right because it
it's too like close to like being real
agree it's
scary i used to be depressed i'd like
finish of the episode my god i'm [ __ ]
sad
what is it about now it's the society
where
women are basically slaves basically and
they have to wear these suits and then
in a section of the u.s like this
religious cult essentially took it over
and infertility is like spreading
everywhere like so many people cannot
have kids so women who have been able to
have kids or do have kids they were
abducted and pulled into this colony
to be vessels for these high up
religious people
to have children so like they impregnate
them in this weird ritual
like ritualistic religious ceremony and
then once they have the kids
then it's like they're just kind of
dispensable and they just take the baby
and they're kind of like slaves so they
make them work and do all this stuff
yeah that's what knew something but it's
so much just like
that he got that one that guy liked
so a bunch of ukrainian women were in
dubai vacationing
and they all were setting up a photo
shoot where they were all naked on like
a balcony on are they from dubai
or they're just now the ukraine
they flew to dubai i guess party
vacation and they all got
naked on this balcony and a bunch of
people from
the like neighboring buildings saw and
it's
super conservative in dubai you're
supposed to cover up you're not supposed
to like show
that game yeah uh they actually found a
few of those women's instagrams because
one of the women have like a huge side
tattoo on her thigh oh wow and they all
got deported and arrested for that
whoa well now let's let's now
here's the thing let's just discuss this
a little bit
um that's hard to do with all those
actions
i'm not there's a lot of tanning going
on um
the fourth woman just has a flat ass i
know right she's like i guess i'll take
this picture
they're all jenny just [ __ ] do it
brendan all booties matter okay
yeah jenny just take the [ __ ] picture
she's the one that needs that ruffle
underwear you know yeah yeah the one
that like
rushes up your ass crap yeah there's
like a special type of underwear that'll
make
flatter booties look bigger and it's by
like getting up into the crack
there's also workout pants number five
was ready she was ready
number five number five so so are they
in prison now
they got arrested and i think i believe
most of them have already been deported
but uh they're trying to figure out who
every single one of those women were
they found 11 of the i think 20
something you better get back to ukraine
girls
this is one of the first models that
were actually deported because of her
tattoo
they were able to find it i think
they're doing that thing where they
found this girl and then they're going
through instagram to find them
who's playing the piano yeah there's one
man in the group
they were arrested for public debauchery
and creating pornography was he was he
arrested two or no
uh i don't know i just play the piano
oh man they're kind of [ __ ] yeah dubai
doesn't
dubai does not [ __ ] around no know what
you're doing man man this isn't that
isn't it crazy some
some what some women can do with their
instagram though and like how they can
like pose and look on and
you see them in real life and you're
like you're like what happened
two different pieces what the hell is
wait a minute
that's her [ __ ] with the filters or
something like you don't really look
like
that filter joe rogan did on his
daughter did i oh yeah
literally was like a woman and he looks
like like fairly attractive like you
know girl next door and i was like
it was joe rogan it was crazy some of
these filters
that's insanity khloe kardashian got in
trouble for a body filter recently i
guess they created new technology where
they will do a filter even on your body
yeah it'll like yeah it'll work
come on now i could have used that the
other day i took that picture
women are kind of caught in this weird
dilemma though with like with like their
makeup and stuff because i see some
women who's like wearing so much makeup
and they look so perfect on their
instagram but you see it in person
you're just like that is not looking
like
you guys like that when women wear like
a lot of god it's giving off the wrong
impression for girls too because
although the show's called keeping up
with the kardashians it's like yeah
everyone's trying to keep up with the
kardashians but that's not
real and also like how chloe's mad at
that one that
wasn't filtered she doesn't look bad and
now she's getting all the brains she's
getting all the sympathy we're like girl
good for you
for speaking your truth it's like yeah
what's that post a [ __ ]
filter that's nuts yeah i think she came
out yesterday with the poster maybe two
days ago saying that
um she was always known as being like
the ugly fat kardashian
and that and so she wanted to be very
protective of the way
she's putting out her image now and that
she is having the standard
thrusted upon and i love that she goes
goes this is me and this isn't
photoshopped yeah it is
no that's that's that's kim right there
no it's not that's halloween that's
chloe that's chloe
oh see how the title says khloe
kardashian wait where's the title i see
it
scroll up chin khloe kardashian so she
goes this is
me and it's not uh photoshop dude her
body's ridiculous
now are those abs sprayed on yeah
definitely so this isn't really her
but it gives girls like in high school
or college who are trying to
keep up with the kardashians it gives
them this [ __ ] false sense of reality
like that ain't real man
this is also the live video that she got
in trouble for because she went on live
to prove that like her body looks like
this
but there's a split second where the
filter kind of comes off and you see a
little bulge
jump out and come back in wait wait wait
mia khalifa actually caught it posted
about it and uh
put khloe kardashian on blasting like
you're trying to make it seem like this
is your body you have this perfect body
and you're proud of it but you put a
filter over your life
and mia
now you can yeah wow it's unhealthy
yeah well not only that but i'm sure
that there's been like
you know they they i don't think there's
any secret that the kardashians have
done like a lot uh
like surgically yeah absolutely which is
i mean it's fine like if you want to do
it or whatever you know but
i'm not against it you know but i just
think it's like
kind of crazy that the standard like
even add the filters you add all these
things it's like
i'd rather look nicer in person so like
i wear like a tinted moisturizer and i'm
like i don't probably look that great on
my instagram
sorry guys but like i would rather wear
like something where you don't
see me and you're like yeah got on her
face
so what else you got jen
that was it for yours right there is it
oh no there's one more
one more there you go okay so there's a
video of a
giant lizard i believe it's over in
thailand it walked into a 7-eleven
searching for food and it's running a
walk
yeah my son saw this and he we just
watched godzilla and he goes dad is that
a baby godzilla
basically dude yeah basically look out
he's so [ __ ] big i know like what do
you do if that's your 7-eleven
just wait for him to leave yeah wait for
him yeah he's gonna eat all the snacks
[Music]
yeah hopefully you didn't fall down how
the [ __ ] did you how did i wonder how
long those
those live for like how old could that
be they're so big like could they live
like they live like a hundred years or
something they live a while it seems
like they would have a long time they're
awesome he's probably pissed he's
probably like you built this
7-eleven on my yeah my land like this is
my
it's my domain i was here before you
it's nuts
second largest that's the problem people
always encroaching on it you know on all
the
animals land it's like what do you
expect then of course the cougars gonna
come eat your kid
this right here uh some person was able
to sneak onto the ufc football team for
a day
go into the jacuzzi with the players put
on a jersey actually play on the flight
yeah another player's like who the [ __ ]
is this guy he took a security guard
afterwards i'll show you the list of
everything he did
so guy gets prosecuted into the football
abrasion building drama case center
mixes in so well i know he realizes he's
imposter
in the jokes jacuzzi sits in the jacuzzi
with other players they don't get
suspicious dumbasses
grabs a meal nobody realizes something
is off grabs a jersey and a helmet
gets dressed for practice makes on the
field starts feeling
a football staffer finally realized some
guy's living out his dream
tight move right so funny
yeah i think that's dope they're saying
that school should probably hire him
to make sure no one else could reach the
school because he knows how to do it
yeah the school isn't that hard to
breach though to be fair
is usc especially right now yeah ufc is
not hard to reach that's interesting
it's surprising that no one else
saw him was like who is that guy though
well if you the puck the kicker and i'm
like oh that's probably
all right man we're on a team there's
120 guys on there 120 guys we knew
everybody y'all did yeah man we we had a
crazy guy coming to the break in the
locker room one time and he was looking
for like crack
and he started like trying to he's
telling us he had the aids
and tried attacking the the players well
what you don't want to do
is in the the corner that he went into
this like eight in the morning
the corner that he went to where all the
guys from like the fifth ward in houston
we're like real hard [ __ ] gorgeous
like lawrence vickers mark fenton so
these boys you know they
lit this dude yeah damn
i'll try and sneak on i'll try to do it
yeah you don't want to sneak in a
football team especially dude everyone
knows each other though it's not like
oh oh i'm bradley from orange county i'm
new to the team
nah [ __ ] what no we know we all know
bradley rewards kids
what else you got jen uh this right here
the little nause x lawsuit
so it's been settled and i guess they're
saying that all the shoes even the ones
that are sold they need to be bought
like returned
dude someone's going to keep them and
they're going to be worth so much yes
who's going to return them you said that
yeah they're going to pay i just like oh
i lost them they're going to see me
hot in the streets [ __ ] rocking those
things i bet you they're worth hundreds
of thousands of dollars it's gonna be
super expensive but that's all that
happens so as part of summit nike says
anyone who doesn't return their shoes
for a full refund
will have to contact mischief if they
encounter a product issue defect or
health concern
so basically they're just not
responsible something happens to them
yeah
[Music]
dude those are going to be the most
sought after shooting since yeah red
octobers
that's nuts right october i don't know
what the road is the kanye west i know
the kanye west joints the yeezys the red
october so
kanye before diaz was was with nike and
his red octobers go for i don't know
fifteen grand
look at that those yeah right there
fourteen grand those are the red
octagons i'd never wear those you never
wear i would not you wouldn't have them
that's crazy
you guys would oh my god dude i would
sleep in those
what i'm supposed to huh i hurt listen
i'm you know
what everyone should help that's fine
you're not real sneaker heads it's not
forever
these are too big for me like way too
big but uh it's like
it's like how was the fashion in
singapore
i don't know i mean it's like mixed like
people wear suits a lot it's like it's
kind of like walking around in
new york it feels like there's just the
you know business yeah
at least where we lived anyways because
we were right down in the city think a
lot of people looked at me strange
because i probably look like a bum i
just walk around with my messy hair and
like
wait for you my my gym wear i'd be like
running by people in their suits and be
like
but they're very judgy over there
anyways yeah
all righty so this city if plymouth is
asking residents
if they see people with their dogs that
don't pick up their poop to call 9-1-1
crime must not be very high up there
where's where's city of plymouth
minnesota
minnesota yeah all right minnesota
they got a lot going on in there right
now no they have nothing going on
they got the trial that's in minneapolis
all right and this call 9-1-1 yeah if
you see someone not picking up their
dog's poop
9-1-1 9-1-1 i guess it gets crazy like
another
cop's like i'm on my way i don't know
all right yeah
like that's one chin we talked about
this before this monkey that has a
neurolink chip
put in its burn uh so check this out
i'll play real quick
so that monkey is getting bananas fed to
him whenever he's following that little
pattern right
there's a joystick there you can
interact with sid right but then
what's crazy about it is it looks
plugged in now but now it's not plugged
in so he's actually doing it with his
brain
with their brain activity see the
unplugging
because they would do this like planet
of the apes he's able to control that
thing with his so
he has a chip in his head right now is
he okay yeah but is he doing it with his
hand right there
yeah so that it's just a joystick to
show but then they unplugged it and he
gets bananas
yeah bananas are trying to put newer
links in people yeah so we don't have to
have our phones with us we could just
kind of control our phones
you know that's coming yeah oh
definitely i mean
you're returning robots you don't you
down for that absolutely not
hell no so then they took the joystick
away even there and then he was still
doing it yeah he's doing it yeah it's
all on his own
dude society's worried about the vaccine
because they think it's gonna
you know the government should be able
to track yeah you get a chip
yeah i couldn't do that [ __ ] that yeah
is that it that's it
michelle we love you you're the best
that was awesome thank you so much
that was easy i know went by fast uh
this cruise in naples next week naples
florida
april 15th to 17th austin texas almost
all shows are sold out so we added a
show thursday night
that's april 22nd through the 24th
austin texas and just announced houston
texas
may 25th 22nd take it at f-a-t-k-z.com
chappelle where you going to be
may 15th raleigh north carolina there
you go
good night's comedy club tickets
trapezelacy.com misha we thank you for
being part of the show
yeah you're the best guys and scooter
shout out to scooter yeah
scooter keep on trucking scooter yeah
all right we're out love you guys
what's up i guess i'm first always hi
chappelle lacy
here uh shout out to my boy matt helders
from arctic monkeys i think he designed
this
so this is great and then uh i'm rocking
this shirt with the uh
w tap vans it's a collab i think it's a
japanese collab
that vans did i don't know i'm not that
big of a sneaker head according to
brendan because i don't like the
metro red yeezys or something like that
october what are you calling so
bro these all in every dope boy steve
he's the young jesus right here
basically what huh the easiest the
easiest regular
those are like the ogs that everybody
everybody gets
listen you go atlanta every dope boy got
these on right here all right man well
you're in la though
go to chris show we gotta go easy
these are also my workout shoes i'm
trying to break them in
get them get the metro red easy for 10
grand
uh naples next week naples florida the
week after we added shows in austin so
go get tickets
f-a-t-k-z dot-com vulcan gas company get
them
okay